chez moi
je suis isolé et c'est ma première
grosse vente outre-mer se méfier des
sociétés de sécurité qui applique
simplement des matrices m'avait demandé
un audit des installations
le florentin n'est pas une simple pierre
précieuse c'est une légende
et c'est cette idée qui fera de cette
vente une van dyck historique si le
monde pas au dessus de 40 millions on
pourra considérer cette vente comme un
échec dont vous serez responsable
[Musique]
j'ai appris que vous avez perdu votre
mère avec quand même âge que moi on va
prendre un dessert quelque part
[Musique]
c'est parti besson du confort et d'être
en train de subir en vol organisé
monsieur vous propose cet homme
travaille avec moi symonds m'a dit oui
je sais vous avez vous géré que ce type
est ce qu'il ya d'autres choses pour les
callosités pense enfin pas si tu savais
rien en justice avait battu arrête je
suis comme toi aujourd'hui
t'es pas comme moi tu seras jamais comme
moi
[Musique]
tout petit conflit c'est pour me balader
autre changement là
quelqu'un que tu connais
cette pierre c'est une saloperie qui
porte malheur est que toi qui peut
arriver à savoir